there's a new movie coming out called
the American Society of magical Negroes
I want to show you a clip of this
trailer which uh has gone viral for all
the wrong
[Music]
reasons I know you can feel their
discomfort
Aaron watching you walk through a room
full of white people was the most
painful thing I've ever seen excuse me
sorry I don't want to take you to a job
interview there's a recruiting class
starting right now and we got to get you
in
it welcome to the American
Society of magical
Negroes I don't really understand that's
real Apparently that is actually a real
thing that they're making uh have
already made I guess and will be coming
out and that's the plot of the movie
basically the premise is that white
people are so volatile and violent that
black people are constantly having to
appease them in order to keep the peace